[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 136 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Ock Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick how you doing
hey Mark I'm good how are you I'm good
I'm not actually here with you you're in
you're in stuck I know I'm not where you
are not today anyways not today today
we've got some pretty amazing content
we're talking about robots so we're
talking with riot today about
reinforcement learning and the research
that she and her team have been doing
out a deep mind and this of course also
plays a role in the robotics space so
that is a fun thing to be diving into
and I'm glad we've got her joining us
today but as always we start out with
our cool things of the week and we will
end with our question of the week and so
question of the week is how do you
connect a Google cloud source repository
to an existing git repository because
that is where everything is at with code
is kind of be able to have a git
repository and you got to be able to
connect it to wherever else you're going
to store it and in this case the Google
cloud source repository so Marc cool
things of the week sweet first we want
to mention the AI adventures the new
video that you Fang one of our
colleagues has put out I think about a
week ago and he talks with Megan rizz
doll who's also one of our teammates
about how to make a data science project
with Kegel so you should check that out
nice
we recently also announced capability to
predict your future costs with Google
cloud billing cost forecast do you now
have a nice visualization and some like
numerical declarations of basically what
your projected forecast for your costs
are gonna be for the month so there's a
question so this will give you some nice
prediction for sort of costs you can
expecting based on your current usage
patterns nice and another cool thing of
the week that we want to mention is the
link in our show notes for the Kegel
competition winning solutions this is
something that was put together by one
of their community members I think in
conjunction with some of the other team
members but I'm a hundred percent sure
although it says in their site a listing
of the different ones who were involved
somebody I know out of Huo AI so
basically they pulled together all the
winning solutions or many of the winning
solutions that you see in cattle
competitions and I'm constantly telling
people when they're asking like where to
get started when they want to explore
data science to
explore Kegel look at you know the
different projects are out there so this
is very helpful if you want to look at
what's been done and see if you can
recreate it absolutely and if people
should remember Kegel is on the GCP
podcast episode 84 back in 2017 so if
you want to learn more about Kegel
definitely go back and check that out
yeah you guys talked to Wendy which was
great yep finally we announced a new
project a new open source project called
a jib which is for building Java docker
images better I like this this is a
really cool Java tool that has
integration with maven and Gradle so you
can just add the plug-in to your build
and basically have your java application
container eyes in no time at all I
really like these sort of tools that
make these kind of workloads a lot
easier to manage so that makes me happy
to see ya the containers gotta get a
little container plugin I got to get
some containers in there absolutely yeah
awesome all right Marc I think it's time
for us to go talk with Raya let's go do
that
so this week we are thrilled to have
with us where I head sell who is a
senior research scientist from deep mind
and we're going to talk about
reinforcement learning and navigation so
thank you for joining thanks Melanie
so right can you tell us a little about
yourself your your background in this
space
sure I've been at deep mine for the last
four years I lead one of our research
groups in the deep learning area work on
problems in robotics and reinforcement
learning lifelong learning a bunch of
different subjects that that I'm excited
about before this I worked at SSRI
international I was at Carnegie Mellon
for a little while and before that I was
at New York University where I did my
PhD with young laocoon so a lot of
neural networks trained in different
ways over the years for different things
what inspired you to go into robotics
research to begin with I really loved
the idea of writing code and coming up
with algorithms but then going out in
the real world and seeing if they worked
or not if I did robotics then I could
take my algorithms out I could run them
on a mobile robot that we could that we
had and I could see whether or not with
the robot ran into the tree or went
around the tree first problem of mobile
robotics avoid the trees it also
robotics brought me into machine
learning
because we really wanted ways of making
the robot behavior be adaptive I didn't
want to run the robots on paths that all
looked the same or on roads with
markings I wanted to run the robots in
the forest or on paths and in the grass
or through shrubbery where it would have
to identify where the obstacles were and
where the clear paths were and that
required machine learning that required
adapting over time so that sounds really
interesting
what sort of like what a lot like I
don't know anything about machine
learning what allows you to do that kind
of thing that lets robots basically what
see space the way that we did it then
was to sort of collect data all the time
we'd label that data as to whether or
not it was the ground or an obstacle and
then the robot would learn that
immediately and so and it would train a
neural network to make a decision either
good to drive or an obstacle bad to
drive there and that worked well and it
allowed the robot to adapt and to change
its its decision but what we actually do
now is reinforcement learning maybe I
should explain the difference between
reinforcement learning and machine
learning sounds great people are
probably familiar now with things that
we call AI systems that might do things
like recognize objects in images or help
make some decisions and that's done
usually using supervised learning where
we have a big data set of for instance
images and each of those images has a
label attached to it like this is an
image of an apple and this is an image
of a monkey etc and you train a neural
network to produce those labels by
teaching it and the data set stays
exactly the same and that's really
important to make the learning work well
what if instead we want our algorithm to
take actions in the world and the only
feedback we're going to give is a reward
either a positive reward or a negative
reward so instead of giving labels and
sort of drawing data from a data set we
want an algorithm that can interact with
the world have feedback that comes as
positive or negative rewards and change
its behavior based on that that type of
learning is both more powerful because
then the algorithm is actually
interacting with the world and able to
take actions for instance driving
instructions but it's also a lot harder
say I want my robot to
be able to drive around a room it has to
make all of these decisions about when
to turn left and when to stop and when
to go faster and when to get slower and
then at the end I say that was good or
that was bad you hit things or you did
well and the algorithm then needs to
figure out where did I make the mistake
or where did I do the thing that was
good and it needs to do something we
called credit assignment get a good
reward and I need to figure out how to
change my neural network to incorporate
that information and that's what we call
reinforcement learning and it's very
much the same as the way in which we
think that for instance a dog learns to
do a trick by using a positive reward
when it does the trick but but it is
quite different from supervised learning
or other types of machine learning and I
know that deep mine is well known for
the experimentation and exploration with
Atari games this is sort of a starting
point or a well-known point you know
when we start talking about
reinforcement learning which games
granted mark is all your area of
expertise so I know you love that kind
of stuff
one area you've been studying is dealing
with navigation what helped drive the
current research that you have I mean it
sounds like obviously your interests in
the space your exploration around
spatial awareness in the past how did
you decide to go down this path with
reinforcement learning for things like
Atari games you don't need a lot of
memory you need to learn how to play the
game so we talk about an agent learning
to play the game that's that's the usual
term that we use in reinforcement
learning is that the algorithm that's
changing over time is getting rewards is
called the agent and it interacts with
an environment which could be an Atari
game or it could be amazed in the case
of navigation and navigation really
brings a whole other level of difficulty
to it because you need to have a memory
of where have I been before where am i
right now where am I trying to get to so
you need to incorporate all of these
different cues and when I'm talking
about amazed I'm not talking about a
maze that you get to see from the
outside that you get to see the whole
thing now imagine a 3d hedge maze where
you can't see beyond your current space
and you need to try to have that spatial
representation that spatial
understanding that says I know where
I've been before and I know where I'm
going to try to get to and I'm going to
try to learn the path to get to that
point
so I just thought that it was a really
interesting area of research it was very
challenging and so we did some research
that showed that we could train our
algorithms to solve these 3d mazes and
that we could train agents to do that
where the mazes were sort of a game we
actually used the doom engine that's to
create all of these different mazes and
try to just have the agent get from
wherever it spawned to a goal location I
mean if it gets to the goal location
then it gets teleported somewhere else
and it needs to find its way back again
so it both has to do exploration as well
as remembering where was the goal and
finding its way back there very quickly
and we trained algorithms we trained
agents that were better at doing this
than a human and we did that by
incorporating memory into the algorithms
into the neural network itself and
that's a bit different than what we
think about traditional robotics
algorithms for doing navigation usually
start by let's build a map and then we
can run a path planning algorithm on the
map and then we can send the control
instructions to the robot to follow that
path through the map instead here we're
doing it all intrinsically with instead
of an explicit map we have an implicit
representation and that's much more the
way that we navigate which I find really
interesting so you talked about both the
simulation and robotics in the real
world I'm guessing that you do your
training in the simulation how does that
work with the translation between both
things I'm guessing the real world is a
little more complicated than the
simulation like what's the their
challenges there yeah absolutely
the real world is is very hard robotics
in general with reinforcement learning
is very hard I mean why is it hard well
the world has a lot more noise and
complexity to it than the simulations
that we create and that makes these
algorithms which are visually based
right you're looking at an image that
makes it awfully hard to operate it's
also hard because the amount of data
being used so the agent that can learn
to navigate in mazes better than a human
can learns for over a billion steps in
the network which means that's about a
week of 24-hour training and that's not
just one agent but that's usually about
a hundred and twenty eight different
distributed agents learning at the same
time multiple different agents
distributed across
Network right exactly similar spin
that's exactly why we use simulation is
because we can run again and again we
can speed it up we can run it 24 hours a
day and we can understand which
algorithms work just curious are you
using tensor flow yes nice so in terms
of the work that you're doing the
streetwise navigation research that you
guys were doing you were using some
real-world data is that right so after
working for a while with these simulated
mazes like I said using quake or doom
engine they were really good to work
with but I really felt like we weren't
really demonstrating that these
algorithms would work in the real world
and we wanted to have at least some of
that real-world noisiness and complexity
and somebody here that I work with
currents Mun Yin said we have Street
View and Street View is a really
interesting set of data and probably
everybody know Street View has used it
at some point this gives you an
on-the-ground sort of panoramic
interactive interface with a map with a
city and so we said what if we turned
this into an interactive RL environment
and trained our agents there but we took
Street View in an area for instance all
of New York City most of Manhattan and
we turned that into an interactive
environment so on each frame on every
step then the agent gets an image that's
just like you would see if you were
using Street View but without any of the
arrows or other information and it gets
to decide on an action to take it can
turn in a circle it can look up and down
or it can take a step and if it takes a
step then it will move forward to the
next panorama in Street View if there's
an edge there and and that allows the
agent to actually walk across New York
City and try to find different goals so
we made different sorts of games here
and tried using those same algorithms to
see if the agent could learn to explore
New York City and what were some of the
algorithms that you used so we've been
mainly using an algorithm called Impala
which is an actor critic method of
reinforcement learning it works very
well distributed so you can think about
it as there are a bunch of different
actors say a hundred and twenty eight
different agents they've all got a copy
of the neural network that we're
training and they're all
all somewhere different in New York City
in this virtual environment Street View
they're all in different parts of New
York City and they're all trying to find
their way to different goals and that's
the sort of gameplay and then there's
one learner and all of the updates to
the neural network come to that learner
and it puts them all together in a nice
way and and learns over time and that
that's the algorithm it's almost making
you think of like a scavenger hunt yeah
it is that's that's a bit how we thought
of it did it would be a scavenger hunt
or sort of a taxi task or a courier but
you have to go from one location to
another location if you get to that
location you get given a new place to go
to and we just watched the agents after
their train sumak all over the city the
interesting thing was when we started
training with Central Park right in the
middle of this big area of play usually
in New York it's pretty simple if people
know I'm sure that some people know New
York City or visited it's pretty simple
you go down the block there's this very
regular street layout but then all of a
sudden they're Central Park and there's
only three I think different roads that
cross central parks the agent actually
needs to learn ah if I need to get
across the Central Park I'm gonna need
to take one of these streets that go
across
similarly in London the agent needs to
learn where the bridge is over the
Thames over the river so that it can get
from one side to the other side
efficiently and it does learn all of
these things so I'm guessing that what
you were talking about before with the
agents weren't given the map beforehand
they had to learn that while they were
driving their round right exactly so the
agent never sees the map never gets the
advantage of seeing the map it just sees
an image of the street ahead of it and
it needs to explore and sort of load up
its brain its own neural memory with all
of this information my understanding
from the way your network structure
works is that it's modular and it's
usable for transfer learning to be able
to move from one city to another city
after we figured out that this did work
and that we could train an agent to move
around one city we we thought well
that's interesting but it's doing that
well a lot because it's just memorizing
the city we said we want to be able to
have an agent that can navigate not just
in New York but then in London and in
Paris and if it gets to a new city
there's some things that we have to
learn we have to learn where the
neighbourhoods are and what the
landmarks look like and things like this
but there's a lot of things that we
carry with us there's a lot of transfer
of
that we do from Sydney to City and so we
want to see if that was the case so we
built an architecture that was more
modular where there's part of it that is
general and that is applied to each new
city and there's part of it that's just
city specific and over time that part of
the neural network that is city specific
learns to encode just the details the
where's a water tower or where's the
where the best bridges across the Thames
what is Central Park look like learns
these specific things and the to work
very well just being trained together
and you can plug and play though it's a
little bit more and that's a recurrent
neural net that that's right it's the
politics right Isabel St I'm a long
short-term memory I've heard about grid
cells can you tell us a little bit about
what grid cells are and how they play a
role in this research when we think
about Biological navigation or
biological spatial understanding we
think about these neurons that have been
found in the brains of mice and rats
that are called play cells and grid
cells there's a few other types there's
border cells head Direction cells but
can focus on place cells and grid cells
and and there's been amazing research
the Nobel Prize was just one a few years
ago by Edvard moser who discovered the
grid cells these are neurons in two
areas of the brain and grid cells are
very general and they just measure how
far it is that we're walking that we're
moving along so think about it as if I
walk down a street then I'm going to
have a neuron in my brain that's
counting every one meter and it's firing
every one meter that I step there's
another one that's firing every meter
and a half when I take a step you know
and I when I get to each meter and a
half another one that might only fire
every 10 meters as I'm walking along and
these are hexagonal II arranged in the
brain so that their their reactivity is
hexagonal as you walk through the
environment and they give a way of
measuring both direction and distance so
when I take a nice complicated path
wandering around my neighborhood say at
home if you ask me at any point to stop
and point back to where my home is I can
just reach out an arm and point straight
back to where home is
even if I've taken some circuitous route
we think that's because of grid cells
place those are different place cells
memorize a specific place you have a
place cell that goes off in the kitchen
of your home and nowhere else in the
world at least you can think about it
that way as being a unique identifier
for different places in the world
interesting so one of the things that we
found a few years ago when we started
doing this navigation research using
recurrent neural Nets is that if we
trained an agent to simply move around
an environment accumulate its estimate
of of where it was over time so
basically be able to do that pointing
tasks that what we would get is inside
that neural network we would get
something that looked a lot like grid
cells and we did some more tests and did
a lot of different experiments and we
just published our results last month in
nature and this was a joint work between
the neuroscience group here at deep mind
and the deep learning group and it was
very interesting to find that these
types of neurons that underpin spatial
navigation in mice and rats look very
very similar to the grid cells the
neurons that we have in our completely
artificial neural networks that were
training so that points to some
fundamental similarities so I'm actually
quite curious because this is
fascinating
was it the plan to build something that
works the way say like our brain works
or was it that you were doing this work
and we just found out off to the fact
that oh this actually seems to be
working the same way mice brains work
well it was a little bit of both my
colleagues Andrea Benigno and darshan we
were working on this from the beginning
together so they were talking about grid
cells and I was talking about robots and
you know but we were working on the same
code base on same thing and so we really
just started looking for it at the same
time that it was there you know that I
thought that's how research works it was
it was an exciting discovery though and
then it took a couple more years to
really convince ourselves that this was
what we were seeing and also to
demonstrate if you train the neural
network in such a way that these grid
cells emerge that the agent that has
those grid cells can then do things like
shortcut navigation it can take a
shortcut in the same way that we can
agents that don't have that are going to
retrace their own paths again so it
completely changes the behavior of the
agent in terms of being able to you know
point towards where you
to go and find that shortcut if it's
there a lot of other types of behavior
as well but basically we were trying to
repeat some of the fundamental work
experiments that we're done with rodents
and see if they applied also to our
agents and just to be clear although
most of the research has been done with
mice and rats neuroscientists are quite
certain that grid cells and placed cells
are something that exists and all
mammals are at least most mammals there
are 3d grid cells in bats for instance
so is the shortcuts one of the surprises
that you found in the research is there
is there are other surprises that you've
seen that you didn't expect
that's a good question the shortcuts
were exciting because they weren't
actually surprised we predicted that and
then we and then it took us a long time
to come up with the experiments that
would actually prove it and and that's
exactly how you how you want it to work
you want to have a hypothesis and then
eventually be able to demonstrate it I
find the reason why I love doing
reinforcement learning is because you're
training agents that end up with some
behavior and you don't know what that's
going to be in advance and you can train
agents that cheat in many many different
ways for instance I work in manipulation
as well with robot manipulation trying
to pick up objects think about how do I
train a robot arm to pick up a ball off
of a tabletop and you say well you're
going to give that robot a reward if it
gets the ball to you know 10 centimeters
off of the tabletop so what is the agent
learn to do it learns to simply flick
the ball for instance so that it bounces
into the air which is easier in a way
than actually picking it up since we use
simulators a lot agents are extremely
good at finding the bugs in the
simulator if you want to find a bug in
your simulator to retrain an agent it's
going to find the bug in the simulator
in some way of a reward hacking coughing
that sounds like some good opportunities
around security
yes exactly this is this is done in
Security Research well so what are some
of the challenges you had especially
when you were doing the research in
terms of streetwise navigation scaling
it to very large environments was
definitely challenging we spent a lot of
time just saying
can we run on an area the size of New
York that's got 8,000 nodes in that
graph panoramas that were working with I
can give most of the credit there
towards future
Moravsky who's the lead author on that
paper actually and he really was able to
make that work both through
architectural II you know coming up with
better ways to manage memory and manage
tensor flow and etc also algorithmically
training the agent with a curriculum so
it starts out learning about places that
are close by and then it's horizons
expand and it eventually learns the
entire city so that was a challenge any
time that we work with actual real
robots that's a challenge you know it
feels at least like it's 90% solving
problems that are not interesting not
publishable not important but they have
to be solved so that you can do the 10%
of exciting real research so so maybe we
can bring it back to sort of like a
practical level in some ways like so
this seems to be useful for for
navigation stuff is it just useful there
like where can we see people eventually
at least using this research I think
that if I want to you know find my way
across New York I'm going to use Google
Maps and the very standard algorithms
that are used they're very good
algorithms to do routing but I think
that there's reasons where we might want
to say just based on the visual
information what can I see here and what
can I infer so for instance a blind
person that wants to navigate and wants
an assistant might not just want to know
where to turn
which Google Maps can give that
information but also what does the
street look like and some other
information about what is there visually
or some notion of how navigation would
work from the point of a visually based
algorithm rather than a an algorithm
that knows the underlying map there's
other interesting ways in which one
could use this if you've ever tried to
navigate around a city where you don't
know the language it can make it very
hard because you don't know how to read
the street signs even so being told to
turn right on Street X isn't meaningful
if you don't know the language or don't
know the alphabet in particular so there
I think that we could give more
semantically guided information that's
based on the visual appearance of the
area more fundamentally I'm hoping that
we will be a
to continue to give information to the
neuroscientists about the ways in which
these things might work in the brain one
of the applications there is that
they've discovered that the grid cells
in the brain are very related to
Alzheimer's disease and so there's a
strong relationship there and that if
your grid cells are not performing well
then you're more likely to be in stages
of Alzheimer's so I'm not sure what we
can do with that connection but it's
very interesting well that's how usually
research goes a lot of times you don't
know really where that's gonna go yet
but still the potentials is exciting in
some ways if somebody wanted to explore
the work that you've done recently see
how they could use it in their own
research you know how would you
recommend them exploring it what
resources would you suggest that they
check out especially for reinforcement
learning yeah there's a lot of good
material on the deepmind site we have
all of these blog posts that both give
you a really nice high level
understanding and also give you some
resources at the end of that blog post
to drill deeper to go to other articles
or go to the actual journal publication
that's probably where I would start yeah
I'm curious too what's something that
you've seen in the robotics research
space in general in the recent years
that would have blown your mind several
years back if you think about it now so
the work that Boston Dynamics has done
in robotics has always been amazing and
years ahead of its time so this is the
Atlas robot that now can do backflips
and Spot mini the doglike robot from
from Boston Dynamics that can you know
open doors and navigate incredibly well
of course I am going to say that these
don't use any machine learning or very
little machine learning and and that's
actually great for us who do learning
based robotics because it sets the bar
really high and I'm really excited to
see if some point we can have humanoid
robots doing backflips
from a machine learning point of view
instead of a optimization and control
perspective on the learning side I think
that the work of the group at UC
Berkeley has been really amazing they've
been able to have robots do things like
tie knots in
after a single demonstration by a human
of the type of knot that they'd like to
be tied or robots opening doorknobs and
such also work that they've done with
the group at Google brain this is
wonderful and I know we're running low
on time right was there anything else
that you wanted to mention that we
hadn't already covered or are you gonna
be speaking somewhere soon I just came
back from a conference so I'm not I'm
going on my way to a summer school where
I'll be talking the Transylvanian
machine learning summer school I don't
have any big talks planned until next
year probably but we're just at the
beginning of really understanding AI and
how there's a lot of things that we call
AI algorithms but real AI is where we
start to understand more about cognition
and the human brain and I think we're
just starting to scratch the surface of
that and I find it thrilling not just
for the types of discoveries and types
of scientific research that we can do
with this but also because it helps us
understand the human mind great thank
you again for joining us we really
appreciate giving the insights about the
research you're doing around navigation
around reinforcement learning thanks
Melanie
thanks mark thank you so much thanks
again Ron for coming on to the podcast
you spending some time with us to
explain what your team has been
researching and getting a little bit
more familiar with reinforcement
learning I think now it's time for us to
dive into question of the week how do
you connect Google cloud source
repository to an existing git repository
this is an interesting question and
something I've tackled myself so if
you're familiar with Google Cloud source
repositories they're basically our
hosted private git source repositories
but you may already have see a github
repo or a bitbucket repo or maybe you
host your own get instance on something
else maybe something like it lab and you
want to be able to connect that existing
git repo to a Google cloud source
repository maybe because that's just
where it is you could always use Google
Cloud source repository by itself which
is fine but you know maybe you want pull
requests or some other features we don't
necessarily have but you may want to
connect to Google Cloud source
repository because that's where all the
hooks are for things like container
builder a lot of our debugging tools
that require source things like that
nice so there are definitely a few
options so if you're working on github
or bitbucket we already have
integrations so you can basically go to
connecting to a github repository in the
Google Cloud console we have basically
some dropdowns that you can fill in all
the details for your github
or your bitbucket repository and all
that kind of stuff and it'll
automatically synchronize between the
two so that's already pretty
straightforward which is pretty nice and
as those changes come in from your
outside repository you know then that
can fire off things like container
builder and things like that but it's
also worth noting and I put a
description in the show notes as well
that you can also manually do this as
well if you have a custom setup or
something like that
the way I've done this in the past and
it works quite well there's relatively
easy way to mirror git repositories and
so you can set up just a cron job but so
something like a GCE instance that
basically mirrors the repository and
then the cron job will just immediately
fetch what's on the the riri mirror over
and over again and push those details up
and that works really really well as
well done that and it works really
nicely and then you can hook up all your
things that work with Google Cloud
source repositories well thank you for
giving us all that insight so mark where
you gonna be in the next month next well
I'll be it next next oh yeah next week
next no yeah the next next week I'm it
next there you go yeah and you'll be
there too I believe we'll both be
annexed next week and we will have a
booth that people should come by and say
hi to us we will definitely be there in
the mornings and a little bit in the
afternoons we'll have some swag to give
out yep there's some stuff in particular
that you should come by early because we
may run out but we always have some
other things like stickers and shirts
that we will have probably throughout
the day so yeah yeah definitely come by
I'll be speaking on a Gunners as well so
if you're interested or and open-source
and game stuff I'll be there we actually
were trying to look at like out what are
our favorite talk is gonna be but
there's so much content enough time this
morning so I'm kind of amazed at the
amount of stuff that's gonna be
happening in next I'm really excited to
see what happens this year and also
super excited to meet everyone who
listens to the podcast and the wider
Google cloud community they're always
really lovely people and we have a lot
of people were gonna be interviewing too
that'll be fun
yeah and then I'm also actually right
before next going to be giving a talk at
PyCon Russia so if you're out there for
that conference you should definitely
find me absolutely awesome
well Melanie thank you for joining me if
you get another episode of the podcast
thank you Mark and I thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]